it seems like a lot of geopolitics a lot
of international military even conflict
is around energy so how does your
thinking about energy connect to what
you see happening in the next 10 20
years maybe you can look at the war in
Ukraine
or relationship with China and other
places through those lines of energy
what what's the hopeful what's the
cynical trajectory that the world might
take through with this uh drive towards
Zero Energy Zero cost energy so the
United States was in a period of energy
Surplus until the last few years some
number of years in Trump and I think
some number now the current
Administration with President Biden
um but we know what it means
um to basically have more than enough
energy to fund our own domestic
manufacturing and living standards
and I think that by being able to
generate this energy from the Sun that
is very capex efficient that is very
climate efficient
gives us a huge Tailwind
the second thing is that we are now in a
world in a regime for many years to come
of non-zero interest rates
and it may interest you to know that the
really the last time
that you know we had long dated Wars
supported you know at low interest rates
was World War II where I think the
average interest rates was like 1.07 in
the tenure
and every other War tends to have these
very quick open and closes because these
long protracted fights get very
difficult to finance when rates are
non-zero
so just as an example even starting in
2023 so the Practical example today in
the United States is President Biden's
budget is about 1.5 trillion and for
next year that's not including the
entitlement spending okay meaning
Medicare Social Security right so the
stuff that he wants to spend that he has
discretion over is about 1.582 trillion
is the exact number
next year our interest payments are
going to be 455 billion dollars that's
29 of every budget dollar is going to
pay interest
so you have these two worlds coming
together right Lex
if you have us
you know hurtling forward
to being able to generate our own energy
and the economic Peril that comes with
trying to underwrite several trillion
dollars for war which we can't afford to
pay when rates are at five percent means
that despite all the Bluster the
probabilistic distribution of us
engaging in war with Russia and Ukraine
seems relatively low
the the override would obviously be a
moral
reason to do it that may or may not come
if there's some nuclear proliferation
but now you have to steal man the other
side of the equation which is well what
were to happen if you were sitting there
and you were Putin let's deal man
setting off a tactical nuke someplace
okay I'm getting calls every other day
from my two largest energy buyers India
and China telling me slow my roll
I have the entire world looking to find
the final excuse to turn me off and
unplug me from the entire world economy
the only morally reprehensible thing
that's left in my Arsenal that could do
all of these things together will be to
set off attack nuke I would be the only
person since World War II to have done
that
you know it's it seems like it's a
really really really
big step to take
and so I think that
X of the clamoring for war that the
military-industrial complex wants us to
buy into
the financial reasons to do it and the
natural reason resources needs to do it
are making it very unlikely
that is not just true for us
I think it's also true for Europe I
think the European economy is going to
roll over
I think it's going I see a very hard
Landing for them which means that if the
economy slows down there's going to be
less need for energy
and so it starts to become a thing where
a negotiated settlement is actually the
win-win for everybody
but none of this would be possible
without zero interest rates in a world
of zero interest rates we would be in
war
so you believe in the financial forces
and pressures overpowering I believe in
the humans
I really do believe in these even in in
international War more so there I think
the Invisible Hand and by the Invisible
Hand for the audience I think really
what it means is you know the the
financial complex and really the Central
Bank complex and the interplay between
fiscal and monetary policy
um is a very convoluted and complicated
set of things
but if we had zero interest rates
we would be probably in the middle of it
now
see there's a complexity to this game at
the international
level where the nation some nations are
authoritarian and are there's
significant corruption
and so that adds uh from a game
theoretic optimal perspective
you know the invisible hand has is
operating in the mud
preventing War
the person the person that is the most
important figure in the world right now
is Jerome Powell he is probably doing
more to prevent more than anybody else
he keeps ratcheting rates it's just
impossible it's a mathematical
impossibility for the United States
unless there is such a cataclysmic moral
transgression by Russia so there is tail
risk that it is possible
where we say forget it all bets are off
we're going back to zero rates issue a
100 year bond we're going to finance a
war machine
there is a small risk of that but I
think the propensity of the majority of
outcomes is more of a negotiated
settlement so what about I mean if you
what's the motivation of Putin to invade
Ukraine in the first place if Financial
forces are the most
um the most powerful forces
why did it happen
because it seems like there's other
forces at play of uh
maintaining superpower status on the
world stage yeah it seems like
geopolitics doesn't happen just
with the Invisible Hand in consideration
I agree with that I can't beg to note to
be honest I don't know
um
but he did it
and I think it's easier for me
to guess the outcome from here it would
have been impossible for me to really
understand it is
what got him to this place
but it seems like there's an end game
here and there's
um there's not much playability
yeah I feel like I'm on a sturdy ground
because there's been so many experts at
every stage of this that have been wrong
well there are no experts well on this
uh there are no experts Lex I understand
this well okay let's dig into that
because there's some because we just
said Phil helmuth is the um is the
greatest poker player of all time he has
an opinion yeah he doesn't he's so they
would be mistaken hey poker Phil has an
opinion Ivy has an opinion as well on
how to play all these games
meaning an opinion means here's the
lines I take here are the decisions I
make
I live and die by those and if I'm right
I win if I'm wrong I lose I've made more
mistakes than my opponent
I thought you said there's an optimal
so aren't there people that have a
deeper understand
a higher likelihood of being able to
describe and know the optimal the
optimal set of actions here at every
layer well they're they're they're being
theoretically set of optimal decisions
but you can't play your life
um
against a computer like meaning the
minute that you face an opponent and
that person takes you off that optimal
path you have to adjust yeah
like what happens if a tactical nuke
it would be really bad
um
I think the world is resilient enough I
think the ukrainians are resilient
enough to overcome it it would be really
bad it's just a it's an incredibly sad
moment in human history but do you
wonder what U.S does
is there any understanding do you think
people inside the United States
understand not not the regular citizens
but people in the military do you think
Joe Biden understands do you think I
think Joe Biden does understand I think
that I think they have a clear plan I
think that there are
few reasons to let the gerontocracy rule
but this is one of the reasons where I
think they are better Adept than other
people
um you know folks that were around
during the Bay of Pigs folks that
hopefully have studied that and studied
you know nuclear de-escalation
we'll have a better Playbook than I do
my suspicion
is that
there is a you know in an emergency
break glass plan and I think before
military intervention or anything else
I think that there are an enormous
number of financial sanctions
that you can do to just completely
[ __ ]
Russia that they haven't undertaken yet
um and if you couple that with an
economic system in Europe that is less
and less in need of energy
because it is going into a recession it
makes it easier for them to be able to
walk away while the U.S ships a bunch of
you know LNG over there so
I I don't know the game theory on all of
this but does it make you nervous
that uh or we're just being
temperamental does it feels like the
world hangs in a balance like uh it
feels like
at least for my naive perspective
I thought we were getting to a place
where surely human civilization can't
destroy itself and here's a presentation
of what looks like a hot war or multiple
parties involved in escalating
escalation towards a world war is not
entirely out of the realm of possibility
it's not I
would really really hope that
he
is spending time with his two young
twins
well this is
part of what I really I really hope he's
spending time with his kids
agreed but not kids not just kids but
friends and the the uh he may not have
friends but
it's very hard for anybody to look at
their kids and not think about
protecting the future
well there's uh partially because of the
pandemic but partially because of the
nature of power it feels like you're
surrounded by people you can't trust
more and more I do think the pandemic
had a effect on that too the isolating
effect a lot of people were not their
best selves during the pandemic